twenty-six-year-old muhammad yuba's
father died
while trying to salvage belongings from
his heart
as fire ripped through the camp i can't
explain in words
how i feel emotionally at this moment
the loss of my father
is devastating for me and my family my
shop was also destroyed
but it doesn't bother me salma kathan
and their family lost
everything including their home
after facing so much trouble in burma we
fled to this place
now it seems like we're refugees all
over again
some witnesses say the barber fencing
around the camp
stopped people from escaping the fire
the fire has
swung the spotlight back on the
struggles the trauma
and the tragedies faced on daily basis
by everyone here
it has been more than three and a half
years since nearly a million
rohingya fled myanmar into this distant
corner of bangladesh
turning it into what is now the world's
largest refugee camp
camp community leaders are seriously
concerned about the fire hazards
it is about time that the rohingya
volunteers are given training on fire
safety by government and aid agencies
it is very critical that rohingya
refugees learn and be aware of fire
hazards and safety and there should be
door-to-door public awareness on such
hazards
lives could be saved in the future
unhcr and other aid agencies along with
government
trying hard to provide shelter and
assistance
well honestly the situation it's
devastating this fire is
it's on such a huge scale it's like
nothing we've ever seen before
you've more than 45 000 people made
homeless overnight
10 000 shelters just completely gone and
not only that but also health centers
learning centers nutrition centers
they're all gone
so it's so important that unhcr with the
other humanitarian partners that we work
together
to try to provide basic assistance but
also psychological support for people
who've been through trauma again and
again
this tragedy is a reminder of the
vulnerability of rohingya refugees
who are caught between the increasingly
precarious situation in bangladesh
and a new political reality of a
homeland now ruled by the military
government
responsible for the genocide that forced
them to flee
tanwich audrey al-jazeera cox's bazar